Trascrizione: Lucia Di Pietro
Revisore: Barbara Dalla Villa
Voglio farvi una domanda.
Per alzata di mano:
chi vorrebbe abitare
in una città più vivibile?
(Risate)
Credo tutti.
Ci troviamo a Catania,
una città di 311,000 abitanti,
bella e contraddittoria,
che è stata valutata all'84esima posizione
su 107 province analizzate
in merito alla qualità della vita.
Ogni anno "Il Sole 24 Ore"
stila una classifica
basata su 42 indicatori,
suddivisi per 6 macro aree tematiche.
Ogni provincia, viene valutata in merito
ad ambiente e servizi, cultura
e tempo libero o demografia e società.
Quest'anno, questa classifica
ha indicato Milano
come provincia più vivibile.
Secondo l'approccio dell'economista
e filosofo Amartya Sen,
ci accorgiamo che il dato, nella
valutazione dello stato di una città,
assume valore nella misura in cui
questo viene letto
all'interno del suo contesto territoriale.
In particolare,
la vivibilità viene definita come
[L'opportunità per ogni individuo
di scegliere liberamente
di avere accesso ad una risorsa
e di ottenerla.]
Secondo le ultime analisi
contenute nelle direttive generali
per il piano regolatore,
Catania è una città caratterizzata
da una forte saturazione edilizia,
con edifici prevalentemente residenziali.
Il carico urbanistico ha caratterizzato
una forte impermeabilizzazione dei suoli,
e un'eccessiva concentrazione
del traffico veicolare,
in particolare nel centro urbano.
Le periferie come, ad esempio, Librino,
Montepò, Nesima, S. Giovanni Galermo,
risultano incomplete di servizi
e infrastrutture per il cittadino.
Le aree destinate ad attrezzature
per il cittadino o ad aree verdi,
oggi soddisfano lo standard minimo
solo per il 65%.
Immaginate di avere
un appartamento modesto
e di tenere sempre una stanza chiusa.
Senza poterla mai utilizzare
senza una reale motivazione.
La categoria più critica è risultata
essere quella relativa al verde pubblico:
basti guardare un'area verde nel quartiere
della periferia di San Giovanni Galermo.
Questa immagine è presa da Google Maps
ma non perché io sia una persona pigra.
Quando io e Alberto,
un mio amico e collega
con il quale lavoro da un po',
siamo andati a scattare questa foto,
ci siamo trovati d'accordo
nel non voler scendere dall'auto
per scattare la foto
con la macchina fotografica.
Però vi assicuro che io e Alberto
non siamo persone timide.
Eppure, in quel quartiere, in quel luogo,
e in quel momento, non era proprio il caso
Proviamo adesso a farci alcune domande:
perché alcuni quartieri sono percepiti
come più sicuri, e altri come pericolosi?
Perché alcuni sono belli e tranquilli,
e altri invece no?
Perché alcuni sono reputati
più vivibili rispetto ad altri?
Se proviamo a pensare a queste domande,
ci accorgiamo dell'importanza
dell'interazione tra individui,
società e ambiente
E, nella misura in cui questi elementi
si mettono in relazione tra di loro,
si produce il paesaggio, come:
[insieme di attività, relazioni e culture
che nel tempo si manifestano.]
Ma di cosa stiamo parlando, concretamente?
Pensiamo che quartieri e comunità
siano la stessa cosa?
Secondo quello che dice Diers,
un quartiere è definito come una
[porzione di città dove la gente abita]
mentre una comunità è:
un [gruppo di persone
che si identificano con un luogo
e si supportano vicendevolmente.]
Per esempio, In un quartiere
può non esserci
un forte senso di comunità
o di appartenenza.
Pensiamo alla maggior parte
dei quartieri della periferia catanese,
privi di reali funzioni,
definiti infatti “quartieri dormitorio”.
Invece è possibile che tra persone
che non abitano nello stesso luogo
per via di eventi comuni,
lingua, cittadinanza,
vi sia un forte senso di appartenenza.
E le comunità, quando si mettono insieme,
e mettono azioni collettive,
sono molto forti.
Se pensiamo a quartieri mal collegati,
incompleti di servizi,
dove non ci sono infrastrutture,
dove mancano luoghi
dove identificarsi per il cittadino,
in quei quartieri non si vive bene.
Ed è quindi forse una conseguenza
che siano proprio questi i quartieri
e le aree dove attecchiscono
maggiormente le attività criminali.
Se pensiamo a un’area verde,
notiamo come possa scaturire
ed innescare benefici,
non solo dal punto di vista
ambientale ed ecosistemico,
ma anche sociale.
Può diventare dimora di animali,
come uccelli, farfalle, e altre specie.
Al tempo stesso, una popolare area
di ritrovo per la collettività.
Secondo l’approccio di Ezio
Manzini, ingegnere e designer,
gli innovatori nella progettazione
dello spazio pubblico urbano,
dovrebbero aprirsi all’innovazione
secondo una attività
co-evolutiva con chi li abita.
Vi dirò adesso un segreto:
[Tutto parte dall’ascolto.]
E [il primo passo per il cambiamento
è sempre la conoscenza]
in un processo che costituisce un bagaglio
tanto per il cittadino,
quanto per il progettista.
Voglio raccontarvi adesso di una
scelta che ho fatto qualche anno fa
e di come identificarmi in un gruppo
mi abbia permesso di lavorare a un metodo
strutturato su una visione condivisa
e di trasformarlo in realtà.
Circa 3 anni fa ho frequentato
un laboratorio che si chiama
[“I Paesaggi delle Mafie”]
organizzato dal Dipartimento di Ingegneria
dell’Università di Catania.
Quando questo laboratorio è iniziato,
non avevo idea di come
questo avrebbe modificato
non solo il mio percorso
personale e professionale,
ma anche quello di un gruppo di
sconosciuti e inattesi colleghi.
Il laboratorio indaga
se e come è possibile
far emergere determinati
comportamenti deviati,
scaturiti e innescati da
particolari organizzazioni criminali
in territori critici come,
ad esempio, quello siciliano.
Durante il laboratorio
abbiamo collaborato con la comunità
che prende parte al progetto
“Punto Luce” di Save the Children,
a San Giovanni Galermo,
uno dei tanti "Punti Luce"
presenti in Italia
per il contrasto alla povertà educativa.
Durante il progetto abbiamo lavorato
insieme alle mamme e ai bambini
che prendono parte al centro,
che offre servizi sia per i bambini,
come attività di doposcuola,
ma anche per le mamme,
come la Zumba e corsi di nutrizionismo.
Con loro abbiamo costruito un orto
sociale negli spazi esterni della scuola:
In queste foto potete vedere alcuni di noi
mentre lavorano insieme alle mamme
per la costruzione di panchine,
arredi o fioriere.
Lui è Simone, che dovrebbe
essere qua da qualche parte,
e loro sono alcune mamme: lei è Lucia.
Loro sono Floriana e Agata.
Alberto, Nino, Simone,
Enrico, Francesco.
Quando il laboratorio è finito,
abbiamo fatto l’esame finale,
come avviene per tutti
i corsi all’università.
Avevamo però capito, grazie anche
al supporto di ricercatori e professori,
di essere legati non solo da
idee e obiettivi comuni,
ma, soprattutto, da domande aperte
e questioni irrisolte.
Un quartiere non è la stessa cosa
di una comunità.
Cos'è quindi che lega società,
individui e spazi, luoghi?
Da queste nuove domande, è nata
“Whole - urban regeneration”:
un’associazione no-profit
che punta al miglioramento
della qualità della vita delle città,
con particolare riferimento
alle aree marginali.
Noi abbiamo capito che
nel gruppo c’era la nostra forza:
che solamente tramite
il nostro ritrovarci
e il nostro identificarci
in qualcosa di comune
potevamo riuscire a cambiare qualcosa.
Però [Ognuno di noi è un cittadino,
e, facendo parte di un gruppo,
tutti abbiamo la potenzialità di attivarci
e tutti possiamo, insieme,
da un pallet, creare un progetto.]
Voglio farvi vedere alcuni progetti
che abbiamo realizzato.
Questo è “Wired”:
Una installazione che abbiamo realizzato
nel quartiere di San Cristoforo,
in occasione del festival "Ursino Buskers"
Con quest’installazione,
abbiamo voluto ricostruire,
tramite fili di lana, il tessuto storico
e culturale del quartiere.
La gente guardava il quartiere dall’alto:
i genitori mostravano
i luoghi ai propri figli,
gli abitanti riscoprivano strade e vie,
e i fruitori occasionali
ne scoprivano di nuove.
L’installazione, tramite l’interattività,
chiedeva ai passanti, ai visitatori,
di lasciare uno spunto di miglioramento,
una riflessione, un ricordo sul quartiere.
Tramite questa attività, l’installazione,
da puro mezzo conoscitivo
–un plastico architettonico, solitamente
utilizzato per conoscere luoghi-
diventava un contenitore delle idee
e delle visioni per il quartiere.
Voglio raccontarvi anche
cos’è successo durante un progetto
che abbiamo fatto quest’anno
nel quartiere di Nesima, in una scuola.
Anche con loro abbiamo lavorato
alla costruzione di un orto
sugli spazi esterni dell’istituto.
Una mattina, è venuta una mamma
cercando Francesco:
un mio amico e collega
anche lui co-fondatore di “Whole”.
Io sono stata responsabile
per questo progetto,
quindi potete immaginare
il mio stato d’animo e quello degli altri
quando una mamma è venuta da noi
cercando uno dei nostri collaboratori:
eravamo un po’ preoccupati.
La mamma voleva ringraziare
Francesco e tutti noi
perché, grazie al rapporto che
aveva instaurato con il figlio,
che voleva cambiare istituto,
prima di quel momento,
era riuscito a farlo integrare
con il resto della classe,
permettendogli di risolvere
i suoi disagi.
Abbiamo osservato come, tramite il lavoro
su uno spazio comune, su un bene comune,
la classe aveva migliorato
il rapporto tra di loro.
Ma non solo!
Si era riusciti a instaurare
un senso di appartenenza e di cura
nei confronti dello spazio pubblico.
È proprio dai piccoli cittadini
che bisogna iniziare
se si vuole ripensare in chiave
più sostenibile uno spazio urbano!
[Una comunità sana e felice
rigenera i luoghi che abita,
e crea quartieri migliori
e cittadini migliori.]
Questo possiamo pensarlo
se proviamo a rispondere
alle domande che ci facevamo prima.
Molto velocemente,
quello che facciamo noi,
in altre città europee, è capace
di innescare un cambiamento,
di diventare un vero e proprio
attrattore urbano.
Questo è “Tempelhofer Feld”:
un vecchio aeroporto nazista
nel cuore di Berlino,
ed è stato, tramite attività e
progettazione, reintegrato nella città.
Questo è “Nomadic Community Garden”:
un altro esempio di agricoltura su
piccola scala, che è nella City di Londra,
un quartiere molto frenetico,
io ci sono stata.
E lì tutti corrono.
Non si sa verso dove, ma corrono.
È stato capace di innescare azioni simili
sia all’interno della città
ma anche le amministrazioni,
i decisori e gli investitori
che agiscono su quel quartiere, si
confrontano tutt'ora con quest’esperienza.
Ma come facciamo ad arrivare
da questo, un pallet,
ad un progetto di rigenerazione urbana?
“Sovrappasso d’Uomo” è
un workshop di co-progettazione
che abbiamo ideato e realizzato
e che ha visto, grazie alla sinergia
che si è venuta a creare
tra cittadini, progettisti, università,
amministrazione, ordini professionali,
l’impegno fattivo da parte
dell’amministrazione
nel non voler rendere vano
il lavoro di una comunità
che si era attivata
e aveva fatto qualcosa.
Noi abbiamo voluto inserire
"Sovrappasso” all’interno di #CTUser,
un hub molto più ampio
che raccoglie progetti per la città
a partire dai cittadini.
"Sovrappasso” e #CTUser
sono l’esempio che,
se veramente ci mettiamo insieme,
qualcosa può accadere, qualcosa cambia.
Noi vogliamo partire
dalla voglia di rigenerazione,
dalla voglia di rinascita dei luoghi,
per costruire un sapere condiviso,
multiculturale, multidisciplinare,
e democratico.
Sappiamo bene che si tratta
di obiettivi alti,
soprattutto perché stiamo parlando
non tanto di comunicazione,
quanto di dialogo.
Questo tipo di attività costituisce
una ricchezza, come ho detto prima,
tanto per il cittadino,
quanto per il progettista,
che si trova in una crescita
professionale e personale
che non si aspettava
prima di approcciarsi.
Se vogliamo delle città
più vivibili, agiamo.
Facciamo qualcosa!
Anche con piccole azioni
che abbiano la forza dell’esempio.
E in virtù di quest’esempio,
chiediamo che decisori e amministratori
costruiscano politiche in grado di mettere
a sistema tutti questi piccoli gesti,
e far sì che da questo si possa ripartire
per una città migliore, più vivibile.
Quindi ognuno, nelle nostre differenze,
che vengono valorizzate e non escluse
in un processo del genere,
[Facciamo] e, insieme, [Chiediamo.]
Grazie.